non
[Musique]
un nouveau quartier nouvelle maison
l'avis de vincent et marie-eve s'apprête
à changer ses cours elle le 19 décembre
on attend un petit garçon à notre
premier à qui on est bien excité puis on
attend impatiemment le 21 octobre
prochain
ils voteront pour la première fois avec
des yeux de parents les promesses d aide
aux familles ou de baisses d'impôts
seront difficiles à ignorer
évidemment le budget va changer aussi au
cours des prochains mois donc
effectivement tout qu'est-ce qui va être
pris en considération pour améliorer la
situation
c'est sûr et certain qu'on va aller
coûte les futurs parents font le trajet
de la rive sud vers montréal plusieurs
fois par semaine et ont beaucoup
d'attentes en matière d'environnement
6 pourquoi ils seront très attentifs aux
engagements des parties pour développer
le transport collectif
on n'a pas j'avais conscience des
changements climatiques tout seul puis
avec les petits bébés bon c'est un
format encore plus la der de l'avenir de
la planète jeu offre à couy on voit
assez yedder sens signé vers la partie
qui va proposer des airs et se sont
réalistes le power qui a des changements
là ce nouveau l'oeuvre est dans leur
circonscription de beloeil chambly la
bataille sera féroce entre les parties
pour tenter de ravir le siège détenu par
le npd toujours indécis leur coeur
balance le jeu pourrait donner mon vote
en partie comme les libéraux mais je
pourrais aussi très bien aller
complètement al'inverse j'ai donné mon
vote au parti vert s'est donné un peu de
puissance à ses plus petits partis
si ce jeune couple a le regard tourné
vers l'avenir ailleurs au pays d'autres
électeurs ont des préoccupations bien
ancrée dans le présent
[Musique]
à peterborough en ontario monica elliott
est en congé de maternité prendre soin
de la petite pause mais les défis du
quotidien la tracasse et maquillage
le coût de la vie est énorme dit elle
est ce que je gagne en un mois est à
peine suffisant
monica travaillent dans le commerce de
détail et n'a pas vu son salaire
augmenter comme elle le prévoyait la
location canadienne pour enfants du
gouvernement libéral lui donne un coup
de pouce mais elle doit encore être
bonifié croit-elle la préparation de
lait pour nourrir son bébé coûte cher
explique-t-elle 57 dollars pour une
boîte et ça dure pas très longtemps
elle n'a pas décidé à keira son vote cet
automne avec cette mère appuiera des
mesures qui permettront aux parents de
s'épanouir dans leur carrière
[Musique]
e
dans la région d'oshawa c'est le passé
qui occupe les pensées de kemper une
époque où l'industrie automobile était
florissante aujourd'hui c'est tout le
contraire
après trois ans à l'emploi de fabricants
de sièges de voiture il perdra son
travail en novembre
l'annoncé de la fermeture des
installations de gm à oshawa a créé une
onde de choc dans la région c'est une
période difficile tout le monde a peur
en ce moment ce travailleur espère que
son employeur l'entreprise lieu lui
offrira un régime de retraite anticipée
plutôt une indemnité de départ
je ne retournerai pas à l'école à 52 ans
dit il
beaucoup de ses amis sont dans le même
bateau il faut ramener des emplois dans
cette province dit il lui qui votera
conservateur cet automne il reproche à
justin trudeau d'avoir échoué à protéger
le secteur automobile canadien et ses
travailleurs
[Musique]
ce réchauffement climatique au coût de
la vie en passant par une économie en
mutation les préoccupations de ses
électeurs ont quelque chose en commun
ils veulent qu'on leur présente des
solutions concrètes pour suivre le
rythme rapide des changements qui se
répercute dans leur vie